n'allez pas imaginer que gouverner d'une
partie de plaisir
c'est une l'eau des animaux qui prennent
le pouvoir dans une ferme dans un souci
d'égalité mais tout ne va pas se passer
comme prévu
les cochons vont instaurer leur régime
totalitaire qui est racontée là c'est
dans le pouvoir politique mais c'est
dans les cours de récréation aussi je
dis je veux dire c'est que c'est quelque
chose qui se passe dans chaque
entreprise dans chaque là où il ya un
noyau d'humanité de travail de tension
de ceux qui veulent effectivement
imposer leurs choix ceux qui se font
imposer les choix une critique des
rapports humains société mais aussi une
satire de la révolution russe la ferme
des animaux de george orwell un
classique de la littérature qui retrace
l'arrivée de staline au pouvoir un sujet
complexe abordés par ces adolescents de
la ferme de bel ébat et à des certaines
personnes qui sont manipulatrice un peu
et qui donc reprennent les idées des
autres en faisant croire que ce sont les
leurs moi je joue un manipulateur un
cochon c'est celui qui va faire les
grands discours qui va un peu les
supercars et en fait je suis méchante je
samyn distance et du coup ils sont plus
à l'aise s'oublie complètement que ce
que quand on fait la chèvre donc là nous
le mouton on s'oublie
après plusieurs semaines de préparation
le public est invité à découvrir la
pièce les 21 et 22 avril
les rémois
et les moutons de la boyne